Năm nguy sạp rường của tình hành huyên lập trong hiện nước, hàng chút kệ bản của phố lập.
Hãy nghe dưới mất kệ và mất tuyên lập trên kệ tập phần tình có bốn người chết,
hành em mất tích, hành em bị thường, năm y bốn trong năm nay nhà bị tất mai,
sật lợt tà lý thường, nập sól trong nước, nập hơn bốn nghĩ bốn trong năm 2018,
năm mỹ tà miếp và chăm tà miếp con sật cầm bị chết choi,
dầu tính đường cầu chàn bị sật lợt và ngập cũng, kìa nhiều tính sợt thông bị ngập đủ chia cắt.
Tụ tối chíc vụ và mấy trính đợt tích xác tình hình tại các phường,
phần đình phụng quanh chiều tính khánh hoyen, nơi đầm bị nước mập sâu,
khô lập chiêu cắt, với hàng chăm hụt xác tình có nhà bịn gập,
kìa đại nặng này về kinh tế, đời sống hích xức khó khăn,
người dân sấm nhở sự chí viện tư bên ngoài.
Thông hỏi đậm tiên và bây tỏ chí sẻ xác bình nhân dân và đầm bố chí quyền địa phương,
về những kìa thại khó khăn hết sức nặng này này,
tụi tối chí phụ khăn địa đạng nhận nước, lực lực phần bộ tổng ăn,
bơ bên cạnh nhân dân nhất là những lúc họ khăn,
để đạng nhận nước không có mục tiêu nào cao gân,
là bảo vệ được lập trụ hoyen, quan vệnh phổ,
bà chăm lo trong bị dân ngày càng hạnh phúc ấm ngọc,
mặc muốn người dân phát lý tình thành tức được tư phường,
bàn kết phối trận nhau vượt qua khó khăn,
sọng vượt lập lúc dưới.
Tụi tưởng chỉ đạo tình tháng viên phối hợp với bộ phòng bộ công an,
ra sọc khu vượt nập sâu huy cơ sắp lợp,
chú đạo đi dài dân để đưa em khoảng,
bảo cảm tính nạng người dân là tình đau,
bộ tổng đợi tình mọc được phát,
tích tạng vùng bộ phố hạp với phố trận nước không,
tự tối cùng đánh người dân thiếu đỏi,
bàn trời chữ đất,
tụi tưởng lình sát cao kiến tiền nghiên đại trụ đập sơ tán dân,
tụi tất giữ phẩm,
tương dân, phóng gặp lụ tất cả cố đề điều,
bộ dân của bộ công an và các mình bị đạo vi động phương tiện
thiết bị thương hộ hỗ trợ người dân,
sau khi thích tất, khi tiết tất giữ phạm,
chỉ cứ đời thân hỏi chia sẻ của lệnh đạo đàn,
nhé nước tự nhiên dân thành bên yêu cầu địa phương tích tụi
phòng chống sật lợp bảo cảm an toàn đù đặt,
khẩn chưa khó phục biệt, đến thông sau thông,
giúp dân, ông địa gà sống khó phục sản xuất,
bây lâu dài chỉ khủ thống nhất bầu tư,
nâng có thể thống đề điều phòng chống lụ lụng đột sọc xong cầu,
các tất ngành tự trước và cà nhân,
chúng tai giúp người dân thành bên lời dân và các tình kế bắt nói chung,
đàn xịp kể thạy nặng nè,
sau báo ở mưa lụng khóc phục hộ quả, sớm ủng hiệu của sống,
cường cũng cầu gọi của thủ phương tại buổi nằm biệt,
thêm mặt con người chúng rân bộ phòng,
đại thướng phân tân ra, bộ phòng,
chào năm tỷ đồng ủng hộ tình thành bên khóc phục hộ quả trên tay.